how's it going guys Matt here with code
of tech tutorials we're going to look at
another command pattern today we're
going to look at the chain of
responsibility and I'm just going to
implement it in C plus plus talk about
it as I go and that's going to be the
visitor so the visitors
uh the video so all right chain I'm just
going to call this chain
and you'll see why it's chain of
responsibility here shortly I'm just
going to make a few things that need
done here
let's get our C make in here and yeah
we'll make a main for the client code
just like so and I'm going to make uh
just a header where to find everything
for this Main
since it's a small example I'll just
call this chain dot h all right so let's
go ahead and work this up so what we're
generally going to do with the chain of
command is exactly that we basically
have commands or requests and we're
going to hand them off appropriately so
we get to build up kind of a chain of
processing if you will and it should be
somewhat smart
design of course varies greatly
depending on what you're doing and what
you're
chaining essentially this is often a
great way to generically handle incoming
requests and stuff like that that could
have a variety of different options or
things that they they do all right so
we're going to start out with the
classic uh just an interface and we're
just going to call it Handler and mainly
we just well we want it's got to do the
old virtual thing virtual error Handler
oh Destructor here got to be defined
and a few base options that we're going
to need to handle so if it's a chain
obviously you need to have a way to add
to that chain so we got to set that up
I'm just going to make this one have a
set next and it's going to return the
Handler when you do this
and we're going to make this appear
virtual with the old equals zero at the
end also we're going to have in here a
way to handle length
so
what do we want to handle now this can
uh we need some kind of thing to handle
so we essentially need to work that up
for our particular program this could be
anything you might have a struct of
events for example uh and it might have
some certain specifications and you want
your Handler to go through that and do
stuff so sure we'll do that we'll make
that the example where and here we're
going to have a string and just call
this event message you could just pass
in a single simple thing like an integer
or you know anything that's kind of an
ID for what you want to handle but I
like this idea of making events so
message start it up blank and maybe
we'll also have sure let's have an INT
in here you know it'd be better if we
had it kind of enumerated for the
different possible events but we're just
going to have an event ID for now
and just because we're going to make
this really generic so we're going to
handle events we'll pass in here in an
event and we'll also just go ahead and
return an event okay
so just keep in mind that instead of a
vent here it could be anything it's
whatever you're handling but the event
is kind of generic you know you can add
to event if you want to add more stuff
that it processes why it's handled all
right but don't worry we'll we'll
continue we'll get to the chain part we
just got to kind of set up these uh
handlers because in a chain of command
you got to be doing something with the
request all right so
we want to build like a concrete set of
handlers that implements this but we
want a base one in our case we're going
to make a base one that just like
handles cases uh that aren't implemented
basically so let's do that we'll call
this
base Handler and it's going to implement
the the Handler
and this will be like our most generic
one that we can specialize further later
so in this base Handler it is going to
be a concrete clasp but typically well
you'll see here so privately we're going
to handle the next handle Handler
got to be a pointer here
because uh we got to use the power of
polymorphism in this particular example
but we'll just call this uh next Handler
and let's see here let's make a
Constructor Implement stuff we got to
implement we'll start next Handler as
null
so we'll just put that right here so
so that'll just initialize that that way
I don't think we need anything else in
there right now just make sure it starts
out as null and we need to implement set
next and handle see if this quick
actions and refactoring actually works
it uh does not quite but you know I was
saying in one of my videos it's that's
kind of a bug and it somewhat is but
also if you have everything worked out
and your class is correct it should
actually function so usually it's
probably because there's some syntax
that doesn't understand or something all
right so let's implement this set next
here and we want to override it
and yeah we'll go ahead and Define here
and basically we want to make sure it's
actually going to be this class calling
its uh Handler so we're going to use
this we don't really need this here
actually it just sometimes makes it more
clear but we're just going to set this
next Handler to the Handler we're
passing it and we also want to return a
Handler so let's just return this one
this will essentially allow us to chain
handlers you'll see later when we do all
the setting up that's the point of
returning the same the same one
you'll see here a little later all right
of course we gotta Implement our event
handler so we'll go ahead and bring this
down and copy it down over right here
and basically this is going to be like
the root case since it's in our base
Handler so if we don't have any
specialization for the event this is
what it will get what will get called
and that'll make more sense here shortly
as well so we want to see basically is
there a next Handler as if whatever is
currently processing didn't work
it's going to go off to this one so we
need to send it along if there's another
Handler and we'd also want to return the
event so we will just end up returning
whatever the next Handler handles here
oh that should be handled and then we
want to pass in the event event last
sort of using those interchangeably here
but uh I'm calling it event you might
often hear this just says request
whatever you want to call it
all right so we're going to return
whatever that returns otherwise
if it doesn't return anything we can
actually return
I think just this class or default
instantiation of an event
like so all right so if it falls through
this if statement doesn't return it's
just going to return a new instantiation
of an event which will should kind of
flag us to say that it's invalid it will
even start this as negative one so we
can do checks later that's the default
initialization there
the event ID first up all right so we
got a base space Handler here that's all
well and good now we need some
specialization and we got to talk about
what these events might do because
that's basically what our specialization
is going to be based on uh we're just
going to handle events by IDs so we're
going to stick with that but you might
say like you know just something in your
program that's being processed you need
send off to be handled that's probably
what this will be so we're going to
empty my class here and we're going to
put handle uh event one it's what we're
gonna call it weird name for a class I
know
but it's just because we're going to be
kind of passing off based on these IDs
on our case but you do what you want to
do as far as how you want to if on that
if else switch whatever all right so
handle event one we're gonna implement
this
base Handler
and just add some functionality so of
course it's already got this stuff we
can override them if we want and we do
want to override at least the main stuff
we don't need to do anything with set
next that's going to be fine just like
that but we do want to override this
handle for what it does for this special
case so
we'll uh just copy this down
put override on it and we basically want
to say if events.event ID well this is
handle one so we're going to see if the
event ID is one then we'll do our thing
with this I'm just going to do a c out
for now so I'm gonna include i o stream
because we haven't really defined
exactly what what work we're doing but
so we'll just kind of say that we got
here handling
an event
with ID one okay now we do have a
message we can pass along so maybe we'll
just put that in here yeah we'll just
put an event message and we can just go
event dot event message
names are terrible I don't know why I
have an event in there I just you know
let's just do underscore ID or just ID
and just message
kind of redundant to have the event word
in front of those my opinion
now we can just do event.essage and
let's do a Intel and maybe we want like
I don't know make this look however you
want I'm going to just space this
message over a few
and maybe uh make a little arrow here
something like that
okay
so handle event one will literally just
handle ones with one but what if it
doesn't handle it this is where we want
to basically do an else we're not
returning or anything in the first if so
we got to do an L else
um well actually we do need to return
don't we
yeah so we'll return event
yeah that'll be fine I don't know if
we're actually going to use this of well
we might we'll leave it for now uh but
there might be a better thing for
returning in a generic sense but now
that this actually Returns the else is
optional because uh well it's just how
logic works so the fall through case we
want to fall through case basically you
could do this as an else you'd have to
do as an else if you didn't have this
return here but if it's not one it's
going to fall through and go return well
we want to uh do the next Handler
basically this one didn't do it pass it
off to the next so we'll just call this
abstract one or this base one I keep
saying abstract accidentally it's one of
the examples I looked at call it
abstract but we'll just return its call
to handle the event
and that's going to say okay well this
didn't work go into this whole thing
and I think that's all we really need
here we can make some more
specializations of these so we got
handle event one let's do handle event
two check for id2 same thing
so you'd want basically one of these for
each Sherry specific request that could
come in and however you want to identify
it probably get the point here so now we
can probably get to our client code and
see how you might call these
and your actual program which got them
all set up so let's go over to our main
make sure we include our chain.h so we
get all that code in here
and let's set up a chain of
responsibility here so
we got our three handlers kind of know
what they all do let's go
and it'll event one make it a pointer
so we could change it on the fly if we
wanted monkey I don't know saying monkey
again
from the sample I'm looking at has with
animals uh but we just want to do new
and alert for that type don't need to
specify anything and let's and just put
the other ones in here too
like so we got three event handlers you
know you might have more than that but
essentially you've got to set up this
chain somehow that's where the set next
comes in so we'll start with trying to
handle one so let's go event one
set next
and the next one is going to be event
two and of course the set next returns
whatever you pass in so it can operate
on event two do another set next with
event three
there we go we've got the chain started
so now when you make an event or uh
actual event or these should these
shouldn't be named events that's going
to be confusing I'm just going to put
handle in front of all these okay now
we need an event to actually call these
so you can see it operate
so an event
so we need to set this stuff up on this
event we'll set ID so one
set message to why hello there and let's
pass this through um
yeah I'll do a few other runs here
shortly but
essentially we just want to uh all
from this first handle event
which has all the next ones set up pass
in this event and we should be able to
see what happens from here and go ahead
and refresh my cmake
mix a few basic things here make sure we
add change in there and there we go we
should get that as an option to run now
chain there it is
oh I'm gonna do this right I need to
call the handle method on the first
event and that should start it all off
let's go ahead and hit play now what we
expect to see is that event one was
handled and the message has YOLO there
and that should be it we'll do some more
examples shortly so go ahead and hit
play oh we got a failure here what do we
need I probably just forgot the
semicolon all these classes I took it
off my auto complete
this here should be eye handle my
Handler there we go I think we got
everything squared away let's try to run
that again nope still missing something
try to compile just this one see what we
get here
oh I need to include string of course
that's probably the main problem here so
we'll do that try to rebuild and it
looks like it went okay let's give it a
run and there we go Zoom this in a
little bit handling event with id1
message hello there
you guys think of this rasterized font
it's one of the fonts you can select in
uh Visual Studio or not visual studio
just in their console font raster fonts
just trying it out I don't know I'll
switch back it's kind of weird after a
while it looks good at certain uh sizes
but another size it looks terrible and
this one apparently makes wise instead
of dashes that's weird all right so
whatever let's go and do some more
examples
so let's make some more events or if we
change this event it will happen so
change this to three and now let's hit
play
and you see the third one handled it but
what happened how did that go well it's
because it went to the first one didn't
work there so it went to the next one
didn't work there so I went to the next
one actually we could put a little break
point here and just run this and debug
and even just walk through that so as
you can see let's give this a run
I guess we've got to build it in and
debug
all right there we go
so we got on debug and we pass it off so
right here let's step into this function
and we see that it goes into where we'd
expect the handle event one class and
checks if the ID is one of course it's
not because the ID is three and I think
because this is a header it's not
tracking the variables correctly maybe
I'm not sure no it seems to have mirror
okay ID3 so since it doesn't handle it
it goes to this next part this is the
chain so when we go into this one we see
that it goes to the base one and that's
where it does the whole pass off thing
based on what's next in line and you see
it goes to handle event two tries it
since the IDS were wrong it once again
goes back to the base Handler passes it
off to the next one this is the chain of
command in action here initially gets to
the one that actually processes it and
spits out the message does its thing
it does return the event in this case
we're ignoring this final return here
and that's pretty much it
so a few interesting cases there
obviously it could be a lot more robust
as you can see eventually if one doesn't
get processed like if we set this to
four what happens we'll just hit play
um let's step through these you'll see
the console says nothing because it
didn't hit any of the cases and it
actually did something weird here
but essentially it's gonna be you know
it's gonna handle or it's going to
return a default event with uh negative
one so we could go event
turned event now this like making copies
and stuff so it's not going to be Grace
code but we just want to check this
return event
earn event
like
let's get a little visual confirmation
of what happened after I went through
all the handling let's hit play on that
break point
because we should see that returned
event ID negative one because
you would think maybe it'd be four but
we kind of went over this a little
earlier so I'll show you why it's not
for
case that doesn't make sense it's
because of the way we have this base
Handler and return a new construction if
it falls through
so if there's no if it falls off there's
no last handle or never cut handle
returns a default construction of an
event rather than the event that was
passed in so that's why it's constructed
a new one of these making a negative one
so if we wanted it to return the event
that fell through we could just do that
and it would still you know fall through
and you'd eventually get whatever the
actual one was all right so that's
basically it for the chain of command
you just set up that nice little chain
codes on GitHub appreciate you guys and
uh yeah see in the next one man out
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]